eran capaces de presupuestar mejor durante el mes.
Es importante señalar que no alteramos la cantidad de dinero que cobraban,
simplemente cambiamos el entorno en el que entendían su ingreso.
Los indicios del entorno tienen un impacto importante.
No voy a contarles trucos que ya conocen.
No voy a indicarles cómo abrir una cuenta de ahorros
o cómo comenzar a ahorrar para cuando se jubilen.
Lo que voy a enseñarles es cómo acortar esta brecha
entre sus intenciones de ahorro y sus acciones.
¿Listos?
Este es el primer paso:
Refuercen el compromiso previo.
Pensamos en nosotros mismos de dos formas fundamentales:
nuestro yo del presente y nuestro yo del futuro.
El yo del futuro es perfecto.
Vas a ahorrar para la jubilación, perder peso,
vas a llamar a tus padres con más frecuencia.
Pero solemos olvidar que nuestro yo del futuro
es exactamente la misma persona que el yo del presente.
El mejor momento para ahorrar es al recibir el reembolso de impuestos.
Así que hicimos una prueba A/B.
A los del primer grupo les enviamos mensajes a principios de febrero
antes de que presentaran su declaración de impuestos
y les preguntamos: "Si reciben un reembolso de impuestos,
¿qué porcentaje ahorrarían?".
Es una pregunta complicada.
No sabían si recibirían un reembolso de impuestos, ni cuánto dinero sería.
Pero aun así se lo preguntamos.
A los del segundo grupo
les preguntamos apenas recibieron su reembolso:
"¿Qué porcentaje ahorrarían?".
Los resultados:
Cuando las personas del segundo grupo recibieron su reembolso de impuestos,
decidieron ahorrar aproximadamente el 17 %.
Pero cuando les preguntamos a los del primer grupo,
el porcentaje aumentó de un 17 % a un 27 %
en comparación a los que les preguntamos en febrero.
¿Por qué?
Porque están comprometiendo a su yo del futuro,
y obviamente su yo del futuro puede ahorrar 27 %.
Estos grandes cambios en el comportamiento del ahorro
provienen de cambios en el entorno en que se toman las decisiones.
Queremos que sean capaces de reforzar esto.
Tómense un momento
e imaginen formas en las que pueden comprometer a su yo del futuro
a hacer cosas que saben que hoy serían un poco difíciles.
Consigan una aplicación que les permita tomar decisiones de ahorro con antelación.
Lo importante es tener esa responsabilidad contractual.
Número dos: Usen los momentos de transición a su favor.
Realizamos un experimento con una página web
que permite a los adultos mayores compartir su casa.
Pusimos dos anuncios en las redes sociales dirigidos a ese público de 64 años.
Uno de ellos decía:
"Oye, te estás poniendo viejo. ¿Estás listo para tu jubilación?
Compartir casa es una opción".
Con el segundo anuncio fuimos un poco más específicos:
"Estás por cumplir los 65. ¿Estás listo para tu jubilación?
Compartir casa es una opción".
En este segundo caso señalamos que habrá una transición.
De repente, registramos más vistas al anuncio y más gente que se registraba.
En psicología, lo denominamos "el efecto de comenzar de cero".
Ya sea comenzar un nuevo año o una nueva estación,
la motivación de actuar aumenta.
Así que pongan ya mismo un recordatorio en el calendario
el día anterior a su cumpleaños.
Identifiquen el gasto de lo que quieren hacer,
y comprométanse a hacerlo.
El tercer y último consejo:
Controlen las compras simples y frecuentes.
Realizamos varios estudios diferentes
y descubrimos que el principal gasto del que la gente se arrepiente
es comer fuera de casa.
Es un gasto frecuente que realizamos casi a diario,
e implica una lenta muerte financiera.
Un café aquí, un burrito allá…
Se acumula y afecta nuestra habilidad de ahorrar.
Cuando vivía en Nueva York,
al revisar mis gastos noté que había gastado más de 2000 dólares
en aplicaciones para compartir vehículo.
El gasto era mayor que el de mi alquiler.
Me comprometí a cambiar.
Y al mes siguiente gasté 2000 dólares una vez más.
No cambié, porque la información no alteró mi comportamiento.
No cambié mi entorno.
Así que habiendo malgastado 4000 dólares, hice lo siguiente:
Primero, desvinculé mi tarjeta de crédito de estas aplicaciones.
Y vinculé una tarjeta de débito que solo tenía un saldo de 300 dólares mensuales.
Si necesitaba más,
tenía que llevar a cabo todo un proceso para agregar otra tarjeta,
y sabemos que cada clic, cada barrera cambia nuestro comportamiento.
No somos máquinas.
No llevamos un ábaco a todas partes
para calcular los gastos y compararlos con lo que habíamos planificado.
Pero nuestros cerebros son buenos contando cuántas veces hicimos algo.
Así que me puse un límite:
solamente usaría estas aplicaciones tres veces a la semana.
Esto me obligó a dosificar mis viajes.
Comencé a controlar mis gastos de transporte
--para beneficio de mi esposo--
gracias a los cambios que hice en mi entorno.
Así que controlen ese tipo de gastos,
y cambien su entorno para que no les sea fácil realizar estos gastos.
Estos son mis consejos.
Pero quiero que recuerden algo:
Como seres humanos, podemos ser irracionales al momento de ahorrar,
de gastar y de hacer presupuestos.
Pero afortunadamente somos conscientes de esto
y podemos anticipar cómo actuaremos en determinadas condiciones.
Hagamos lo mismo con el ahorro.
Cambiemos nuestro entorno para ayudar nuestro yo del futuro.